.
Okay, ihr habt es doch
bestimmt auch mitbekommen.
Das Licht aus unseren Handys,
Tablets, Computerbildschirmen,
soll blauer sein,
als für uns gut ist.
Zumindest gibt
es inzwischen einige Produkte,
die gegen blaues Licht helfen.
Diese Produkte sollen verhindern,
dass Bildschirme uns
um unseren Schlaf bringen,
dass sie unsere Augen ruinieren oder
dass sie unsere Haut altern lassen.
Vielleicht habe ich auch deswegen
den gelben Hintergrund gewählt,
damit ihr nicht zu sehr belastet
werdet durch dieses Video.
Gehen wir der Sache
mal auf den Grund.
Und schauen uns an,
inwieweit blaues Licht unsere Haut,
Augen und Schlaf beeinflusst.
Und ob euer Blaufilter
im Handy irgendetwas bringt.
Zuerst mal die Basics, als fleißige
Mailab-Zuschauer wisst ihr bestimmt,
Licht besteht aus
elektromagnetischen Wellen
einer bestimmten Wellenlänge.
Sehen können wir
das Licht nur innerhalb
eines kleinen Wellenlängenbereiches
von 380-780 nm.
Das kurzweiligeste Licht
ist violett,
dann kommt blau, und dann alle
anderen Farben des Regenbogens.
Tageslicht, oder auch
das Licht aus dieser Lampe
hat einen Mix aus allen Farben
und sie daher für uns weiß aus.
Eine ältere Glühbirne strahlt eher
gelblich-orangefarbenes Licht aus,
weil diese Lampen mehr Licht
in diesen Wellenlängen aussenden.
Die moderneren LEDs aber auch
die Bildschirme unserer Handys,
Tablets, Computer haben einen
stärkeren Anteil an blauem Licht.
Seit es diese Bildschirme gibt,
gucken wir alle
also stärker ins Blaue.
Ja, und jetzt?
Jetzt holt ihr euch einen Tee, denn
das haben wir noch alles vor uns.
Macht es euch gemütlich.
Leute, digital aging!
...ist das Stichwort...
Dieses Video altert deine Haut.
Es gibt jetzt Cremes gegen blaues
Licht. Entschuldigung, blue light.
Was ist dran?
Gerade im Sommer merken viele, dass
Licht schlecht für die Haut ist.
Nämlich, zu viel Sonnenlicht,
gibt Sonnenbrand,
das liegt an der UV-Strahlung.
Die UV-Strahlung liegt im
elektromagnetischen Spektrum
neben dem sichtbaren Licht.
Nach dem violetten Licht kommt
das ultraviolette Licht (UV),
das ist so kurzwellig, dass
wir es nicht mehr sehen können,
aber so energiereich, dass es zum
Beispiel Hautkrebs verursachen kann.
Und nicht nur das. Gerade das etwas
länger wellige UV-A Licht
kann die Haut altern lassen.
Und zwar indem sie in den Haut-
zellen oxidativen Stress verursacht.
Jetzt ist seit einiger Zeit
bekannt, dass auch blaues,
sichtbares Licht, ähnliche Reaktion
in der Haut auslösen kann,
die Haut altern kann, zwar nicht
so intensiv, aber doch messbar.
Was machen wir jetzt dagegen?
Gegen UV-Licht wissen
wir uns zu schützen.
Da gibt es Sonnencremes die
funktionieren, indem sie UV-Licht
entweder reflektieren, oder,
indem sie das UV-Licht absorbieren
und in Wärme umwandeln,
so oder so, die Haut
wird vor dem UV-Licht geschützt.
Das Sonnencremes aber nicht
vor sichtbarem Licht schützen,
sehen wir daran, das
Sonnencremes unsichtbar sind.
Je nach Sonnencreme haben
wir leichte Lichtreflexionen,
das heißt, es glänzt ein bisschen,
die Haut, aber ansonsten geht
das sichtbare Licht einfach
durch die Sonnencreme durch.
Aber jetzt gibt es Cremes,
die angeblich auch noch
vor blauem Licht schützen.
Gegen "digital aging".
Doch diese Blue-Light-Cremes
funktionieren nicht wie Sonnencremes
sie sind keine Schutzschilder gegen
blaues Licht, wenn sie das wären,
wenn sie wirklich blaues Licht
reflektieren würden,
dann würden die Cremes nämlich
auch blau aussehen auf der Haut.
Stattdessen sollen diese Cremes
einfach nur antioxidativ wirken
und so die Hautalterung
aufhalten oder verlangsamen.
Sehr enttäuschend.
Wie so oft bei
kosmetischen Artikeln.
Doch es gibt noch
einen wichtigeren Grund,
warum diese Digital-Aging-Idee
nicht ganz schlüssig ist.
Blaues Licht kommt ja nicht
nur aus diesem Bildschirm,
das Tageslicht da draußen enthält
natürlich auch viel blaues Licht.
Selbst an einem bewölktem Tag
bekommen wir noch 30 x mehr
blaues Licht ab,
als vor unseren Bildschirmen.
Das heißt, selbst wenn blaues Licht
zur Hautalterung beiträgt,
dann haben unsere Bildschirme
nur einen kleinen Anteil daran.
Und das Cremes verkauft werden, die
ganz speziell für "digital aging"
also für das aging durch
eure Bildschirme gemacht sind,
ist mal wieder nicht
mehr als ein Marketing-Gag.
Zu starkes Licht
kann die Augen verletzen.
Deswegen sollte man im Sommer
eine Sonnenbrille tragen.
Und auch nicht mit bloßem Auge
eine Sonnenfinsternis beobachten.
Verantwortlich für diese Schäden
ist zum einen die UV-Strahlung,
genauso wie zu viel UV-Licht
die Haut verbrennt,
kann zu viel UV-Licht
auch unsere Augen verbrennen.
Und auch langfristig kann
zu viel UV-Licht die Risiken
für bestimmte
Augenkrankheiten erhöhen.
Aber nicht nur das UV-Licht,
sondern auch das sichtbare Licht
kann die Augen schädigen,
und blaues Licht ganz besonders.
Es gibt deswegen sogar
internationale Richtwerte,
für Blaulicht-Intensität.
Aber keine Sorge, dieser Bildschirm
liegt etwa 100-fach darunter.
Aber, zu helles, sichtbares Licht,
kann kleine Schäden in
der Netzhaut verursachen,
die an sich erst mal
gar nicht so schlimm sind,
doch Forscher gehen davon aus,
dass mit jedem kleinen Schaden
an der Netzhaut das Risiko steigt
für eine bestimmte Augenerkrankung,
nämlich die altersbedingte
Maculadegeneration.
Die tritt vor allem bei Senioren auf
und kann bis zur Erblindung führen.
Schutz vor blauem Licht
könnte das Risiko
für eine solche
Maculadegeneration senken.
Die wissenschaftliche Datenlage
ist da leider mau.
Zum Beispiel, manche Menschen
bekommen bei einer Augenerkrankung
vom Augenarzt eine
neue Linse implantiert,
und oft benutzt man
hier eine Linse mit Blaufilter,
um das Risiko für eine
Maculadegeneration zu senken.
Wenn man das jetzt aber versucht
wissenschaftlich zu vergleichen,
dass man schaut,
was für Studien es da gibt,
da fand man,
zumindest nach anderthalb Jahren,
zwischen Patienten
mit normaler Linse
und Patienten mit Blaufilter-Linse
keinen Unterschied.
Und für weitere Aussagen gibt es
leider keine belastbaren Daten.
Das heißt in der Theorie
ist das ganze plausibel,
nur in der Praxis gibt es
wenig wissenschaftliche Belege.
Blaues Licht kann
den Augen schaden,
aber nach wie vor ist da draußen
noch sehr viel mehr blaues Licht,
als wir vor unseren Bildschirmen
abbekommen.
Selbst wenn die Abschirmung
von blauem Licht unsere Augen
länger gesund halten könnte, dann
hätte der abendliche Blaufilter,
sicherlich keinem
besonders großen Anteil daran.
Anders gefragt: Lässt uns unser
Handylicht schlechter schlafen?
Wie ihr bereits aus unserem Video
über Eulen und Lärchen,
also Spät- und Frühaufsteher wisst,
stellt Licht unsere innere Uhr.
In einem gewissen Rahmen könnt ihr
eure innere Uhr verstellen.
Und zwar am besten mit Licht.
Das sieht man sehr deutlich an
Studien wie dieser hier.
Hier schnappte man sich
ein paar Versuchsteilnehmer
und ließ sie tagelang bei
schummrigem Licht drinnen sitzen.
Bekamen die Teilnehmer tagsüber
1 Stunde lang volle Dröhnung
helles Licht, stellten sich
die inneren Uhren vor, das heißt,
sie gingen früher zu Bett.
Bekamen die Teilnehmer
dieses Licht abends oder nachts,
stellten sich die Uhren nach,
sie gingen später ins Bett.
Je heller das Licht,
desto stärker der Effekt.
Das Gute ist, wenn ihr Eulen,
dadurch Spätaufsteher seid,
und eure innere Uhr
früher stellen wollt,
dann müsst ihr euch nicht
morgens von der Sonne wecken lassen,
wie manche nach unserem
letzten Video befürchtet haben.
Also ab in die Sonne,
Freunde der Sonne.
Tageslicht, oder möglichst helles
Licht später am Tag,
in der Mittagspause,
hat den gleichen Effekt.
Das schlechte ist, wenn
ihr abends nicht schlafen könnt
und dann noch
ins helle Smartphone schaut,
macht dir alles nur noch schlimmer.
Und jetzt kommt das Blaulicht in
Spiel, denn für unsere innere Uhr
wirken verschiedene Farben
verschieden hell.
Und blaues Licht wirkt heller
als anders farbiges Licht.
D.h., wenn wir abends zum
Beispiel eine Leselampe anmachen,
mit hohem Gelbanteil,
bringt das unseren inneren Rhythmus
weniger durcheinander,
als ein LED-Bildschirm
mit hohem Blauanteil,
weil er heller wirkt
als er eigentlich ist.
Das wurde z.B. in dieser Studie
getestet. Hier nahm man 9 Leute,
untersuchte sie tagelang
in einem Schlaflabor.
5 Tage lang beschäftigten
sich die Versuchsteilnehmer vor dem
Schlafengehen mit lesen.
D.h.mit einem Buch oder einer
Zeitschrift ihrer Wahl,
und die nächsten 5 Tage beschäf-
tigten sie sich mit ihrem Tablet.
Mit Tablet gingen die Teilnehmer im
Schnitt eine 1/2 h später schlafen.
Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen,
Tablets sind generell spannender
als Bücher, deswegen bleibt
man länger wach,
aber dagegen spricht diese Studie.
Die wurde von derselben
Forschungsgruppe durchgeführt,
nur dieses Mal haben sie die Tablet-
und Buchzeit genau gleich gehalten.
Und nach dem Buch schliefen die
Leute im Schnitt nach 15 min ein.
Nach dem Tablett schliefen sie
im Schnitt erst nach 25 min ein.
Nach fünf Tagen waren die
inneren Uhren der Tablet-User
um ganze anderthalb Stunden
verschoben.
So etwas kann man messen anhand
des "Schlaf-Hormons", Melatonin.
Nachts YouTube gucken,
macht uns also zu stärkeren Eulen.
Zu stärkeren Spätaufstehern.
Jetzt leben wir natürlich
nicht in Schlaflaboren,
das heißt, ob dieser Effekt
auch im Alltag so groß ist,
das hängt auch davon ab,
was ihr sonst so macht.
Für eure innere Uhr gilt,
je mehr Licht, am besten Tageslicht,
ihr tagsüber abbekommt,
desto weniger macht es auch aus,
wenn ihr abends ein bisschen
zu viel Licht vom Handy habt.
In dieser Studie sorgte man dafür,
dass die Teilnehmer tagsüber sehr
viel hellem Licht ausgesetzt waren.
Und fand dann abends keinen
nennenswerten Unterschied
zwischen den Teilnehmern, die einem
Buch zu vor dem Schlafengehen lasen
und den Teilnehmern,
die das Buch auf dem Tablet lasen.
Aber was bringen jetzt
wirklich diese Blaufilter?
Leider ist hier die Datenlage auch
nicht viel besser als bei den Augen.
In dieser kleinen Studie ließ
man die Teilnehmer abends mit
oder ohne Blaulicht YouTube-Videos
gucken, oder Spiele spielen,
und fand keinen
nennenswerten Unterschied.
Andere Studien wiederum
finden einen Unterschied,
man müsste einfach größere
und methodisch bessere Studien
durchführen, um da wirklich
eine Aussage treffen zu können.
Aber, wenn wir speziell über blaues
Licht reden, müssen wir eine Sache
beachten, bei einem Handy oder
Tablett fällt uns generell
viel mehr Licht ins Auge als bei
einer Leselampe.
Bei der Studie von vorhin kam bei
einem Tablet 50 mal mehr Licht
ins Auge als von der Leselampe.
Und wie gesagt,
nicht nur blaues Licht,
sondern Licht im Allgemeinen
verstellt unsere innere Uhr.
Außerdem können wir uns
wahrscheinlich einig sein,
dass YouTube und Instagram und Co.
uns auch wach halten,
unabhängig vom Licht.
Sagen wir so, es ist sicher, dass
uns unsere Handys, Laptops, Tablets
wach halten, nur, welchen Anteil
daran, das Blaulicht hat,
das können wir
momentan nicht genau sagen.
Gesamtfazit: Es
spricht nichts gegen Blaufilter.
Nur solltet ihr nicht glauben,
dass er damit jetzt fein raus seid.
Die Idee hinter Blaufiltern
ist wissenschaftlich plausibel,
aber nicht
wissenschaftlich belegt.
Was ist mit euch?
Benutzt ihr Blaufilter?
Und schaut ihr gerade dieses Video,
obwohl ihr eigentlich
schlafen solltet?
Wenn ja, dann erstens:
Geht schlafen.
Und zweitens folgt mir auf Social
Media, falls ihr das noch nicht tut.
Denn, wenn ihr ernsthaft dieses
Video schaut, anstatt zu schlafen,
dann wird euch das auch gefallen,
aber im Ernst, geht schlafen,
wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)